[Música]
revista de prensa en directo américa de
france 24
rosa pérez más de eu quien más sino tu
rosa para esta sección bienvenida feliz
mañana de miércoles entonces vamos a
abrir el tema de hoy que sacude la
actualidad estadounidense por supuesto
desde que se filtró el borrador de
opinión de la corte suprema de eeuu que
tienen intención de revocar la sentencia
de broadway que dan desde 1973 garantiza
el derecho nacional el derecho federal
en el caso de eeuu al aborto rosa buenos
días raúl exactamente no y para abordar
este tema precisamente era periodista
brace y harris de la cadena
estadounidense en bici nos entrevista a
jan brewer que es la directora del único
centro de aborto del estado de misisipí
que precisamente es la clínica que está
a la raíz de este proceso que está
siendo analizado ahora en la corte
suprema y que como decías podría acabar
revocando esta sentencia de 1973 robert
sus web que al final es la que garantiza
el derecho federal al aborto y
precisamente esta clínica lo que hizo
fue llevar ante la justicia una ley del
estado de misisipí que pretendía
reducir el acceso al aborto reduciendo
el plazo en el que una mujer puede
interrumpir voluntariamente el embarazo
y ahora si finalmente como decíamos la
corte suprema acaba revocando este
derecho federal al aborto es posible que
lo que suceda como decíamos en el
informativo es que cada estado legisle
este acceso al aborto por su cuenta y en
este caso dice brewer la directora de
este centro de mississippi que está ya
dispuesta y pensando en trasladar la
crin a la clínica conocida como sex on
women's health organization al estado de
nuevo méxico y además comenta que pues
lo que más le duele es que si finalmente
estas sentencias acaban siendo revocadas
va a afectar a las mujeres que más lo
necesitan no va a afectar a las que
tienen los recursos financieros para
acceder al aborto en cualquier otro
lugar esto es lo que más me destroza así
es el rosa veamos ahora qué hay sobre
ese tema en la revista tecnológica wired
sí porque precisamente recordemos que
esta opinión de la corte suprema de eeuu
se dio a conocer a través de una
filtración al medio estadounidense
político no y que el texto que se dio a
conocer eran unas discusiones
preliminares de ésta de este tribunal
conformado ahora principalmente por
magistrados conservadores y la duda
ahora es que pasará con la fuente
anónima que filtró este texto a este
medio de comunicación bien lo que se
comenta no en los debates que intentan
abordar esta cuestión es que los
documentos de la corte suprema no están
considerados como clasificados por lo
que no se estaría violando las leyes de
espionaje que incluso esta filtración
podría estar protegida por la primera
enmienda la que protege la libertad de
expresión y que sin embargo si este
documento se consiguió robando hackeando
un ordenador pues sí que podría
considerarse un delito federal rosa
vamos a francia donde muchos medios
también hacen eco
esta amenaza el derecho al aborto en
eeuu pero sin embargo hay otro tema que
llena los titulares la unión de los
principales partidos de izquierda esto
para las elecciones legislativas que
vamos a ver en francia el próximo junio
que dicen liberación de mont y media
parte esa liberación dice jean-luc
mélenchon dejó el partido socialista en
2008 para crear precisamente la francia
insumisa 14 años después el partido
socialista se reencuentra con melanson
por otro lado lo monde señala que hace
una semana ni siquiera los propios
insumisos podían creer conseguir este
acuerdo con el partido socialista que
como recordábamos pues todavía tiene que
ser validado definitivamente por el
consejo de nacional y en media parte el
director de este medio duplex edwy
plenel dice esta dinámica inesperada
ofrece la oportunidad de un cambio por
la vía parlamentaria contra el
absolutismo presidencia y cerramos con
la renuncia de la conocida periodista de
rt ina afinó génova por estar en contra
de la invasión rusa en ucrania rosa
exactamente en un vídeo que ella misma
ha publicado en redes sociales ella dice
que debe una explicación a sus
seguidores que desde hace más de un mes
no conocían pues cuál era la situación
de esta periodista que es uno de los
rostros más conocidos de rt en español
ella dice que pues dejó la cadena porque
está en contra de la guerra no solamente
de la invasión rusa de ucrania sino de
cualquier guerra porque al final quien
sufren más son los civiles y que da
igual quien tire las bombas sea rusia
eeuu francia o israel ella siempre
estará en contra del sufrimiento de la
población civil dice también que putin
ha cometido un error estratégico con
esta guerra porque al final está
reforzando y blanqueando y legitimando a
la otan y que no se puede estar en
contra de la otan y a favor de esta
guerra y finalmente veamos lo que dice
respecto a la propaganda bélica
hablo por mí y yo no voy a hacer
propaganda de guerra ahora bien viviendo
fuera de rusia como vivo ahora ya puedo
decirles que no veo muchos periodistas
que no hagan un trabajo de pura y dura
propaganda de guerra que no se dediquen
a leer o transcribir la propaganda de
guerra de uno de los dos bandos sin la
mayor intención de hacerlo de forma
crítica o de poner en duda lo que les
cuentan sin la mayor intención de darle
voz a los dos bandos y que no me vengan
con el cuento de invadidos invasores
cuando el invasor eran ellos tampoco
daban voz al invadido
renunció no sin esperada y finalmente
también el argumento que acaba dando es
que se bueno que equipará digamos la
censura de rt y sputnik en la unión
europea y otros países occidentales con
la censura en rusia gracias.rosa por
toda esta información en esta revista de
prensa mañana jueves con más pasamos a
saludar a nuestra primera invitada del
día